Speaker 1: A very confused and swollen looking
failed. Former President Donald Trump is promising
a global trade war that would be disastrous for
the American economy. In his latest teleprompter
tirade, remember, Barack Obama was bad for
using a teleprompter Obama. But Trump is,
I guess, good for using a teleprompter. I don't
know. This is Trump's new series of, quote,
policy statements where he's laying out supposed
policy that he will enact if he becomes president
of the United States. I can see why Republicans
are running away from talking about policy,
because every idea is a complete and total
disaster. Will, let's just jump into this thing
in the middle. Here is Trump announcing truly just
a whacked global trade war that would not be good
for the American economy. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: We will phase in a system of universal
baseline tariffs on most foreign products
on top of this. Higher tariffs will increase
incrementally depending on how much
individual foreign countries devalue
their currency. They devalue their currency to
take advantage of the United States as tariffs.
Speaker 1: Did you notice that jump cut there.
Speaker 2: For our producers? Go up. Taxes on
American producers will go down and go down very
substantially. And that means a lot of jobs coming
in. Not only will this system end our gaping
trade deficits and they are massive right now.
Speaker 1: Gaping.
Speaker 2: And bring back
millions of American jobs, It will also bring
trillions and trillions of dollars pouring into
the United States Treasury from foreign countries
that allow us to invest that money in American
workers. I will implement a bold series of reforms
to completely eliminate dependance on China in
all critical areas. We will revoke China's most
favored nation trade status and adopt a four year
plan to phase out all Chinese imports of essential
goods, everything from electronics to steel to
pharmaceuticals. We will also adopt new rules to
stop U.S. companies from pouring investments into
China and to stop China from buying up America,
allowing all of those investments that clearly
serve American interests. We're not going to
allow bad things to happen to our country anymore.
Speaker 1: It's bad. All right. So listen, this
guy is clueless about trade. Now, there's there's
there's so much here. Genuinely. The first thing
about this is the entire framing of this trade and
tariff story is that there's no cost to doing this
stuff. Of course, bring the supply chains home.
Hire American. Buy American. Build American. These
are completely reasonable economic nationalist
ideas that I could get behind. And they're not
bad ideas in some theoretical sense. But people
like Trump and many and all Republicans and many
Democrats as well, they pretend that there's no
other side to this thing. And also they pretend
like this will obviously create American jobs.
Now, first and foremost, the tariffs that Trump
did with Chinese products while he was president,
a recent study found that the totality of that
trade policy cost the U.S. about 250 million
jobs. You can find that study, you can read about
it. It's sort of a technical paper. Maybe there's
a summary of it, but it didn't actually create
jobs. It cost the United States jobs. That's
number one. It's not the silver bullet on jobs
that Trump believes it to be. But what Trump and
others never tell you is, by the way, if we do
this, things will be insanely more expensive. On
the one hand, they complain about inflation and
how much eggs cost and how much everything costs
that to find complaint, you can if things are too
expensive, it's perfectly reasonable to complain.
But then out of the other side of their mouths,
they say, We're going to produce everything here.
But they don't mention how expensive everything is
going to be. The United States, through a series
of cumulative decisions over the last 40 to 50
years, has decided. And when I mean, we've decided
it's not Reagan decided or Clinton decided it's
the totality of our policy has been based on the
idea that we prefer cheap stuff rather than paying
more, but making it all here in the United States.
If all of these things Trump is talking about were
manufactured here in the United States, at least
he's saying it's a 40 year plan because it'll take
40 years to actually make all of that happen and
completely restructure all of these supply chains.
At least he's being honest. But it will become
insanely more expensive and people already can't
afford the inflation we've seen while still being
heavily dependent on China for cheap stuff, which
we prefer. When and when I say we prefer, what
I mean is our economy is built on that. So the
global trade war that Trump is talking about will
never happen. And if it did, it would be insane
what it would do to prices. In this teleprompter,
you know, deranged teleprompter speech. Trump
also, of course, attack Joe Biden. Here's the
beginning of it. We'll just look at a little more.
Speaker 2: Joe Biden claims to support American
manufacturing, but in reality, he's pushing the
same pro-China globalist agenda that ripped the
industrial heart out of our country.
Speaker 1: He's really not.
Speaker 2: It ripped us apart. Biden
and the globalists support raising.
Speaker 1: Remember globalists? Does Trump even
know what that means? Now, is it often just a
way to say Jews? Yes, it's it's meaningless.
Speaker 2: Guys. X is an American production.
They support more crippling regulations, killing
American jobs. They support skyrocketing domestic
energy costs, and they support massive
anti American multinational agreements
that send our wealth and factories overseas.
Speaker 1: It's just a word salad. And remember
here, Trump bemoans regulations. The Trump
administration eliminated some Obama era
regulations on rail, which could be a factor in
the East Palestine train derailment. So on the one
hand, he bemoans regulations. On the other hand,
his supposed reduction of regulations was actually
very, very destructive. It's very dangerous stuff.
And tomorrow we're going to get a quote from Ruth
Ben-ghiat, who's been a guest on the program,
where she says that that whether it's Trump or
DeSantis, the authoritarian direction that this
stuff is going in is extraordinarily dangerous.